so let's face it the way that software
engineers are viewed in hollywood
film and tv has not always been that
great we're always portrayed as either
awkward and isolated
i'm gonna need an unlimited supply
of xena tapes and hot pockets right okay
or mean an antisocial
and i don't even know what this is
but there have been some times where
they've gotten it pretty right like
2014's halt and catch fire was excellent
if you haven't seen that before as well
as silicon valley that's really funny
and also fairly accurate now and again
but of course the absolute most
relatable classic is mike judge's 1999
movie
office space which most people remember
for the lumber scenes or for the printer
scene but i recall mostly for when peter
decides to give up his job to do fire
repair instead
so you sure you don't want us to get
your job
that's one thing i'm definitely sure of
so why is office base such a relatable
movie well i think there's two reasons
for that the first is that overwork
isn't glamorized like it is in other
hollywood tv shows and movies and the
second is that peter is on the verge of
burnout or burning out the whole time
and so i think that is very relatable
for us
so on this blue collar coder we're going
to take a look at burnout we're going to
talk about the symptoms of it and then
we're going to give you five ideas for
how to address it in your life
so what are some symptoms of burnout
well you can feel disconnected from the
job not emotionally invested in it the
way that you normally do you'll have
trouble waking up in the morning and
getting excited about working on it
being distracted or distractible while
you're working on it not being able to
retain that focus the way that you
normally do
often times it can include
anger and irritability
and then we get into things like being
tired and being truly exhausted even
when you're not on the job those are
symptoms as well
and it can also get into physical
symptoms it's also been linked to
depression drug abuse alcohol abuse
headaches and even gi issues so this is
really important it's it has a major
impact on your life and it's something
we should look to address
so the first thing i want you to do is
indulge in a little self-care and by
that i mean five things the first is to
give yourself a big break
this has been a really tough two years
of pandemic and everything else going on
and i know we have super high
expectations of ourselves but
we can't
say that we're going to meet those under
those circumstances in all cases i mean
that's crazy we're holding ourselves to
these crazy high expectations
and when we fail to meet them then we
get on ourselves about it and that
doesn't help at all so give yourself a
break i give you a break how about that
and then secondly
get a good night's sleep that's
absolutely critical
i know that when i get a good night's
sleep i feel so much better the next day
all those little things would make me
irritated before
like water off a duck's back
and the third thing i want you to do is
get outside
and enjoy the fresh air that's really
important a couple of times a day just
get it from your desk
take a zoom call outside on the porch or
do some work outside on the porch
whatever you need just get outside and
get some fresh air
and while you're out there
notice that hey i could be doing that a
lot more i could be
walking or biking or
you know running those kind of things
that's the thing i do i go running every
once in a while and i feel so much
better
when i do every article that i read when
i was researching this
video on burnout the number one thing
they talked about was working out and
the fourth thing i want you to do is
take those vacation days it's really
critical disconnect from the office and
disconnect from tech
and then finally have someone to talk to
that you can honestly open up to
hopefully outside of work certainly
outside of tech would be great if you
can
and
if you can't then most companies offer
mental health plans that you can get
remote help for free usually i've used
better help and it's great
another thing you can do to beat burnout
is to have a hobby something not tech
related that's going to give you a real
sense of accomplishment as you achieve
things with it and make stuff it's
really great and you get a whole new
circle of friends around that hobby
hopefully who are not in the tech
community and that's going to be a
really great support system for you
my personal hobby is woodworking and it
requires zero technology at all
well except for this cnc router which
needs coding but otherwise no technology
at all
another important thing to do to keep
your mind and your passions fresh is to
engage in continuous self learning
software is a very intellectual skill
it's all up here so feeding your mind
with new thoughts new concepts as
opposed to continuously doing the same
thing over and over and over again is a
way to keep your mind really healthy and
engaged
so how do you do that well you can
create some side projects on
technologies that you'd never use on the
job that's one way to do it but i warn
you people tend to beat themselves up
when it comes to these side projects if
they don't complete them
if the point is to learn stuff then be
happy with that it's okay i give you
permission to leave those side projects
behind and not trouble your mind with
that and the other thing is to realize
that sometimes we're in the mood to
learn and sometimes are not in the mood
to learn so if you are in one of those
cycles where you're just not naturally
receptive to new information
that's fine don't push it you don't want
to burn out on learning and you don't
want to burn out on learning that new
skill which actually might be really
cool how do you engage with it when it
in a time when you're actually more
receptive to learning it
so let's talk about that 800 pound
gorilla in the room and that's work
would we get burned out we're not for
work i guess maybe i'll find out at some
point
but what you can do at work really
breaks down into two big buckets the
first is what you can do for yourself
and the second is what you need to do in
conjunction with your manager or your
company so let's talk about what you can
do for yourself and that's really about
time management and also effort
management so
make sure that if you push really hard
for a couple of days that you reel it
back and you try and get into a cadence
where you understand when you're pushing
on the gas and then understand when
you're taking your foot off the gas and
you give yourself that time to recover
from those periods of really high work
and make sure that your team is on board
with that as well so maybe when you pull
back a little bit and they step into it
and when they step back then
you get in there and help out and just
make sure that there's a healthy team
dynamic there so that everybody knows
that we're all human some days we have
great days and some days we have not so
great days and everybody compensates for
that and then also
i want you to embrace the power of
saying
no
that's absolutely critical just that
it's a superpower nowadays actually i
know we all want to say yes to
everything i know we all want to be we
want to take the
all the tickets and go through all of
them but
understand
that you don't want to over commit and
by over committing you're losing control
of your time and so the power of saying
no is really the power to
control your commitment level and that's
not just of stuff that you do at work
but also stuff that you would take on
maybe
at home or some friends you know side
projects things like that
be sure
if you're not gonna be able to give your
100 to it just say
no
and finally let's talk about the things
that you can maybe change at work so the
first thing to do is if you're having
troubles talk to your manager directly
let's give your manager a break there
for a second
if you're on zoom everybody's going to
want to be smiling all the time and
painting a happy picture on zoom and
being all upbeat and perky and that may
disguise what's actually going on
underneath so you need to have an open
and honest conversation with your boss
about what's actually happening with you
and then part of that conversation
should be
saying what a good situation looks like
google actually did some really cool
research on this a while back where they
talked to all their teams and did lots
of surveys
and what they found out was that happy
and productive teams share two common
traits and the first is autonomy they
have a lot of individual control about
what they're working on and the second
is that both they and external parties
value what they're doing so they find a
lot of value in what they're doing so if
you don't have autonomy and you don't
have that sense of value it's easy to
get
burnt out in a situation like that so
whatever you can do in conjunction with
your company and your manager to get the
whole team
into that autonomous and valued state
the better off it's going to be
but if none of that works honestly it's
a great hiring environment out there
super hot right now so if it's not if it
for you and if it if you're burning out
at work and you know that there's just
really no way out of it at this
particular work then there's probably
another good job out there for you
all right well if you found this video
on burnout helpful be sure to hit that
like button but i really want to start a
conversation with you about if you've
experienced burnout and what has helped
you recover from burnout so be sure to
put anything like that in the comment
section down below and we'll get that
conversation started of course the
meantime hit that like button
if you like the video and hit that
subscribe button if you like the video
and you'll be notified the next time a
new blue collar coder video arrives
pretty cool dude
chilling out playing a base walking
around the park how cool is that
freaking awesome i love love washington
it's so good for that kind of stuff yeah
so this is lachemist park this is where
i shot this one particular video mostly
actually i think all of it now is in
lacamus which is beautiful such a great
little park up here in campus washington
all right see you next time